[Music]
do
hello good evening
good to see you all
[Laughter]
oh i just want to welcome you guys to
all to the table um thank you all for
joining us online as well
we appreciate that you're here and
you're very much a part of this family
um so start looking at the calendar so
june there's a lot of things to
be thankful for in june so it's pride
month in june
so that's awesome um let's see there's
juneteenth which was yesterday
and today is father's day so happy
father's day to all of our dads
everyone say what you're excited for
exactly
yes happy father's day um and then
because it's summer we don't have school
going on so all of our educators
we are thankful that you guys are not
working hopefully
you're not working or doing summer
school or any of that stuff uh but we're
thankful you guys are having a break
well deserved well deserved all right so
i got a couple announcements not not too
many
um so coming up very soon fourth of july
we are going to be doing a combined
service um with pleasant pleasant valley
so we are going to actually be doing a
sunday service is going to be at
11 in the morning we will not be doing a
service
um in the evening so our five o'clock
normal service that we do
on that sunday is going to be taking
place with pleasant valley so at 11
o'clock that day so just kind of keep
that in the back of your mind
and then also we are doing a virtual
meetup that is actually happening i'm
currently right now things only been
been around for about two weeks or so
and
if it's something that you might be
interested in if you yet have a meetup
that you're
working with they are working virtually
for those of you
those of you guys who are still not one
percent ready to kind of do face-to-face
stuff yet
um or those of you who are joining us
online and you guys are
in other places besides here that's
local
um and you just still want to have like
some point of connection this is a great
place to be able to do that so if you're
watching online especially
if you just want to type your name in
we'd be able to kind of get that
information
and be able to get you connected and
plugged into that
so other than that or start off with a
word of prayer
lord thank you so much um so much for
bringing us all to here together
uh thank you for this ability to be in
the space
thank you for our friends thank you for
our families
i just want to pray that you open up our
hearts open up our minds to everything
that you have us to hear
um pray that we help us to be present
and be able to connect with you in
christ say i pray amen
thanks
i'm not sure if he's mentioning to me or
don don i think you're getting a signal
from the back they need you i thought
they were saying this to me and i was
like how am i gonna be in two places at
once it's gonna be tricky
but we could try um it's so good to see
some of you guys here
carter so good to have you guys with us
i know y'all
all um we all have our full calendars
in summer and it's nice to be able to
come together for a few minutes
out of the craziness of our week and
experience
that community and um hopefully that
like-mindedness
where our spirits are fed and so during
worship tonight i just encourage you to
let your spirit be fed
we have a god who loves us and wants to
take care of us
and wherever you're at you're welcome in
this space whatever you brought in the
door
it's welcome here and he is
all all consuming and able to carry
all of our burdens and you'll hear the
word fire a couple times
during our set tonight actually
a little inspired by mark winfield who's
speaking tonight he's an enneagram eight
and for those of you who are into the
enneagram
marissa can i get a whoo-hoo okay
it felt very appropriate to talk about
fire a little bit
in our worship um because enneagram aids
can be that all-consuming i i'm very
close to a few enneagram mates and
that word all-consuming fire i would
label almost every aid i know as that
so and i feel like that's a great
picture of god's love
and the way that he can be this thing
that takes over
and transforms us in the best of ways so
allow that to happen in um in whatever
capacity it needs to tonight
all right
no place i would rather be
no place i would rather be hearing your
love
hearing your love no place i would
rather be
there's no place i would rather be
there's no place i would rather be than
hearing your love but here in your love
set a fire down in my soul
that i can't contain that i can't
control
i want more of you god
i want more of you god set a fire down
in my soul
that i can't contain that i can't
control
i want more of you god
[Music]
no place i would rather be there's no
place i would rather be
there's no place i would rather be than
hearing your love
hearing your love there's no place i
would rather be
there's no place i would rather be
there's no
[Music]
i want more of
i want more of you god
[Music]
i want more of you guys
become my embrace
to love you from the inside out
[Music]
a thousand times i failed
cause your mercy remains
and should i stumble again
i'm caught in your grace
everlasting your light will shine when
all else faints never ending
your glory goes beyond all things
your will above all else
my purpose remains the art of losing
myself
in bringing you praise everlasting
your light will shine when all else
faint never ending your glory
goes beyond all things
my heart and my soul i give you
control consume me from the inside out
lord
let justice and praise
become my embrace to
love you from the inside out
everlasting your light will shine when
all
else fades never ending
your glory goes beyond all fame
and the cry of my heart is to bring
you praise from the inside out lord my
soul
it cries out everlasting
your light will shine when all else
fades
never ending your glory goes beyond all
fame
and the cry of my heart is to bring
you praise from the inside
out lord my soul he cries out lord me in
sight out lord my soul he cries
out from the inside out lord my soul
he cries out
so set a fire down in my soul that i
can't can take
that i can't control i want more if you
got i want more of you god
set a fire down in my soul that i can't
contain
that i can't control i want more of you
god i want more of you god
set
[Music]
yes jesus we do want more of you
and come and meet with us here we're
gonna
enter into our prayers of the people now
and um
i was reading in deuteronomy 4 earlier
because it has that
phrase in it that says our god is an
all-consuming fire and i was
trying to remember like what story was
that a part of and before you get to
that part it has this one line that
stood out to me
um in light of our prayers of the people
and it says
what god is like our god that when um
when others pray to him
he is near to them and he hears their
prayers
and that it kind of sums up
what we are doing during this space is
believing that we
are praying to a god who is near to us
and a god who cares about what we're
praying and listens
to the hearts of his people so um i just
invite you into a time
where whatever is on your heart if
there's someone that you're caring
that you know is going through a
difficult time
um or a situation that you know
you are bearing that burden this is a
time to just lift it up together
and um for us to all acknowledge that
god hears and sees the burdens that
we're carrying and he
is here on behalf of um of the
victims on on behalf of the widows and
the orphans
and the downtrodden and um he's the god
who lifts us out of the pit
and sets our feet on a rock and so we're
just going to lift up these prayers to
him
together so please join in and speak out
that person's name or that situation
when we get to that part of the prayer
and just remember keep it to their name
you don't need to share someone else's
details this is a safe space we don't
want to exploit someone else's story but
um but do share those together and we
will lift them up
to god as a community um you guys as
we're going through this first part of
the prayer please
read that part in red with me and then
um we'll open it up for everyone to
speak in together and then i'll say
another short prayer at the end to close
it out
jesus for this city of sacxy texas and
for every city
and community and all of those who live
in them
we pray to you for the good earth that
you have given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you for those who travel
on land sea or air we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering we
pray
to you for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember
and care for them we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear
us and so now we lift these names and
situations
up to you
[Music]
susan
some online prayers the minor and fawn
family for safety and good times
nikki and roy
[Music]
for continued healing for nikki parker
and peace for the parker family
[Music]
do
nora howard
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those that we have kept
in our hearts we pray that they may have
life and light healing and hope
peace and the deep sense of your
presence
[Music]
amen
there's a grace when the heart is under
fire
another way when the walls are closing
in
and when i look at the space between
where i used to be
and this reckoning i know
i'll never be alone there was another
in the fire standing next to me
there was another in the waters
holding back the sea should i ever
need reminding of how i've been
set free there is a cross that bears the
burden
where another died for me
there's another in the fire
[Music]
oh my dead left we're dead beneath the
waters
[Music]
i'm no longer a slave to my sin anymore
and should i fall in the space between
of this world
and i know i will never be alone
there'll be
[Music]
should i ever need reminding of what
power set me
free there's a grave that holds nobody
now the power lives in me
[Music]
there's another
as the darkness falls to him and i can
feel the roar
in the heavens as the space between
where's then
i can feel the ground shake beneath us
as the prison walls cave nothing stands
between us
nothing stands between
[Music]
there is no other name but the name that
is
jesus
he who was and still is and will be
through it all
so come with me in the space between all
the things unseen
and this reckoning i know i'll never be
alone
i know i'll never be alone
standing next to me
[Music]
i can feel the ground
shake beneath us
[Music]
standing next to me there'll be another
in the widers holding back the seats
should i ever need reminding of how good
you've been to me
i count the joy come everybody
cause i know that's where you'll be i'll
count the joy come everybody
cause i know that's where you'll be
god thank you that even when we feel
completely alone
your presence is with us
[Music]
there's never a day that we face where
you are not by our side
where you're not walking through the
valley
or standing up on our mountains
you are a god who is near to your people
you listen to the cries of our hearts
you are close you are not far away
you are within us you are surrounding us
would that sink into the depths of our
souls
would we carry you into every
conversation every situation
every weakness that we carry every
addiction that we face
every stronghold that keeps us back
every relationship that has fallen apart
would you go with us into those places
into those spaces would your presence
fill us up jesus
and would we know that we are not alone
but that the transforming consuming
fire of god is in our very pores
in the breath that we breathe
in the blood that flows through our
hearts god would we find you
pulsing within us
thank you for who you are
thank you for an all-consuming love a
grace that never runs out
open our hearts and our minds as mark
comes to share
may we be ready to hear anything that
you have for us
it's in your name i pray all these
things and thank you for this time
together
amen
[Music]
i love it when it times out like that
all right dawn's gonna take it over but
feel free to turn and say hi
to the people around you if you haven't
already
um
okay so i get the pleasure of
introducing mark to you guys
now okay there's a couple things because
mark has had a very interesting
course of career because there's been a
lot of things i have to kind of keep in
mind so i'm trying to
make sure i have all of these things
done correctly
but i do have one thing i want to point
out to mark before
he i bring him up here but currently he
serves as he's as the executive director
um thank you gentlemen um for
uh baptist news global so he's he likes
there's a lot of writing
there's a lot of writing he's written a
book um then i want to make sure
that where why churches need to talk
about sexuality
which i've not had a chance i've had a
chance to read it's on my
to-do list if there's a lot of things
i've got to get through heavens
but um but he hasn't also a ted talk
which i have
read the baptist pastor and his
transgender friends
um so there's just been a lot of
academic things that mark has been a
part of
um personally for like us for the table
he's been just like a great mentor for
us especially as we are trying to figure
out how to transition into
what we know now is the table he has had
many conversations with brett
101 everything like that and for me
personally i actually got no mark's
work i'm still getting to know him as a
person but from his work
many years ago when i was still
processing my own journey and some of
you guys are
already familiar familiar with that um i
was aware of the his church that he
served at prior
and is it what this is up to debate we
will sure
sometimes we get the pronunciation wrong
but it's wilshire baptist church
one of the very first um i think
southern baptist church is in the dallas
area there he goes southern baptist
churches which is the denomination i was
affiliated with
and when i heard that they came out as
affirming i was still trying to figure
things out
um i was like oh my gosh this is like
disneyland i need to go visit this
church
it was it was crazy to even hear of a
kind of stepping out in that direction
and mark was a part of that conversation
and part of that journey and
and all the things that they went in
through that so i've always been i've
been a long time admirer of the work
that he's i've been putting into
this community and this conversation so
mark can't we hear from you man
thank you
well it's nice to finally meet you all
in person i feel like i know you
in so many ways because uh brett has
become a very good friend
and we meet about once a month just to
talk and share stories and
whatever i've wisdom i've been able to
impart probably pales in comparison to
the wonderful ideas i've learned from
him
that's out of the laboratory of what you
all are doing here
i've followed the whole story from
beginning
through this and i just want to say
thank you for what you're doing
thank you for being a light in this
place thank you for being an inclusive
welcoming community of grace
what you're doing right here in saxi
texas
is amazingly important
so much more we can say about that but i
don't want to take all your time
just talking about that i was 17 years
the
associate pastor at wilshire baptist
church and we went through an lgbtq
inclusion study process that's the
subject of the book
why churches need to talk about
sexuality i tell our story
and it's a guide for other churches to
have that conversation and some of your
leadership team
has walked through that book and we've
had great conversations about that and
we have a lot of friends
mutual friends in common as well it's
it's a it's a delight to be able to be
here and share with you today and
especially also for those of you who are
joining us to be a live stream
um i wish i could meet you in person i
look forward to that
so glad that you're here and know that
your reach
is much broader than you ever imagined
and i'm so thankful for that our
scripture passage today is found in the
gospel of mark
chapter four it's a story that if you've
paid much attention to the bible you've
probably heard
before it's one of the jesus greatest
hits
in a sense mark chapter 4 beginning on
verse
35. on that day when evening had come he
said to them
let us go across to the other side and
leaving the crowd behind him
they took him and with them in the boat
just as he was
other boats were with him a great
windstorm arose and the waves
beat into the boat so that the boat was
already being swamped
but he was in the stern to sleep on the
cushion and they woke him up and said to
him
teacher do you not care that we are
perishing
he woke up and rebuked to the wind and
said to the sea
peace be still then the wind ceased and
there was a dead calm
he said to them why are you afraid
have you still no faith and they were
filled with
great awe and said to one another who
then
is this that even the wind and the sea
obey him this is the word of the lord
well in addition to this being sunday as
it's already been noted this is
one of our all-time hallmark holidays uh
father's day which may mean something
positive to you or it may mean something
painful to you
uh father's day is one of those um
one of those days that is sort of a
second string parenting holiday i think
it you know rightly falls um
between in this summer outdoor grilling
season that's perhaps a reminder of the
kinds of
masculine flame throwing cooking most
fathers are known for
that's appropriate now i'm a father and
we fathers get
often the short end of the stick when it
comes to family remembrances and
celebrations
and that's just fine with me not
complaining about that
in a world with so much history of male
dominance
it's fine for us to be sandwiched
between the greater holidays of mother's
day
and the fourth of july i'm okay with
that
now entire academic studies have been
done on the portrayal of fathers in
popular culture
and you're going to excuse me for just a
moment because just this very brief
moment in time
i'm going to sound like a raging
fundamentalist which i'm not
these studies they point to the way
sitcoms and movies generally don't show
us fathers in the best of lights
i mean just try to think of a few
examples of popular tv shows
where there's a positive compassionate
competent father figure
anyone it's not homer simpson
right there are not many there are not
many
uh the more common themes we see are the
missing father
the absent-minded father the abusive
father
and the all-time favorite the buffoonish
father right
now we know that father's day like
mother's day is fraught with emotions
because there are so many dynamics at
play
i'm especially aware from my work with
the transgender community
that many of my trans friends who are
parents
struggle to find a balance between
mother's day and father's day
and feel they are not accepted on either
day and they struggle twice a year
through this mother's day you know is
the same thing in a way
we can pray on mother's day with a
thousand qualifications
for women who want to be mothers but
aren't for women who are mothers but
wish they weren't
for children who experienced good
mothers horrible mothers
you get the idea the same thing carries
over in a way to father's day but
it seems that we're just not quite as
coherent in our response to father's day
there's just more detachment regarding
father's
and father's day and i think there's a
reason for that
we do by the way we love to tell funny
stories about fathers
and our role as fathers that these are
stories
like about ball games and road trips and
campfires and
home improvement projects gone wrong
i've had a few of those
sometimes these family stories include
tales about how the children pulled a
fast one on their dad
and coerced him to do something he
really didn't want to do
or maybe their stories about children
being afraid to go to sleep
or afraid to go somewhere and how their
father
comforted them or protected them or
encouraged them
and that's where our bible story
connects with us today
jesus has become a kind of father figure
to his disciples
they trust him they follow him they
believe
he's going to provide for them now side
note
i find myself shying away from the
heavenly father language
to describe god in my experience this
phrase has been
so overused and abused as to be
problematic
besides being gender exclusive and in
run-in-the-mill church circles
the label heavenly father sometimes gets
applied to jesus
which really is all sorts of wrong if
you understand the nature of the trinity
that's a whole other sermon or bible
study to itself
put that aside but we see
still here the disciples they're
interacting with jesus
as a kind of father figure and this is
evident in the gospel of mark today
or in another way of looking at they see
jesus as
the proxy for the heavenly father who
should in their view be taking care of
them
so it is that while they're out on the
sea a great storm arises
and they're being battered by the waves
the story says
and in a fashion we would anticipate
from any american tv show
jesus the father figure is unfazed
he's unaware he's sleeping through the
storm
and the disciples they are panic
stricken but rather than waking jesus
with an urgent cry for help
they wake him up with a criticism a
critique
teacher do you not care that we are
perishing
there's an assumption here i think that
if they are being threatened by the
storm
jesus their parent figure their
protector their guide their teacher
should have surely preempted this
problem
another way to hear this question is how
could this happen to us while you're in
the boat with us jesus
now to give the disciples some credit on
the positive side
at least they believe jesus is capable
of helping them in the storm
that's good they've been journeying with
him as he's performed miracles and saved
other people from the raging storms of
life so
they recognize already that jesus has a
divine power
to make things right so good job
disciples
that's nice but in the preceding verses
before we get to this passage today
mark tells us that jesus keeps speaking
to them and to the crowds
in parables and even the disciples
aren't
really comprehending the stories he's
telling
back in chapter in verse 34 right before
our passage that i just read
mark tells us that jesus privately
explains to the disciples the meanings
of his parables
yet they still pretty clearly have not
understood how things work
they expect divine protection because
they are after all in the presence of
jesus
like children who trust that their
fathers also will protect them from harm
even to the point of keeping harm from
coming their way
they expect jesus to anticipate their
every need
does that sound familiar to you it
should
because we're all guilty of this right
it is part and parcel of the human
condition i think
and reality is throughout time
regardless of what deity is worshiped
where
humans have turned to the gods for
preemptory protection
as well as for rescue in times of
trouble
the problem is the world doesn't work
that way
and neither does god always work that
we see in this story a reminder
that sometimes bad things happen
to good people even to people who are
following jesus
so closely that they are in the literal
boat with him
something bad's happening to them now
perhaps you know this truth through
firsthand experience of your own
i sure do three and a half years ago i
underwent a routine
procedure to address compressed nerves
in my cervical spine
never anticipating that there could be a
complication my doctor
had performed the same surgery hundreds
of times before
without incident and yet when i awoke
from the anesthesia
i learned that during my surgery i had
suffered a spinal cord bruise
an incomplete spinal cord injury
that rendered my right arm and my right
hand numb
and nearly useless and that was only
beginning
of an unexpected journey that included
an unstoppable headache for more than
two years
all sorts of other downline
complications i won't go into here
all while my body struggled to rebuild
new neural pathways to receive
communications for my brain
to make up for those that had been
severed i was broken
broken physically broken emotionally
broken spiritually and i was a pastor
it was ash wednesday 2018 when i finally
came
undone as the wednesday night service at
our church ended
in a room about this size in our chapel
i set frozen in my pew i could not move
i shook with emotion i sobbed so
hard so uncontrollably that the pew
and those people who were supposed to be
tidying up after the service
scurried away to not be anywhere near me
perhaps you two have been in this kind
of place
filled with fear filled with anger
wondering
why in god's name this has happened
to you and why god appears to be
sleeping
while you've been praying jesus do you
not
care that we are perishing do
you not care
that's where the disciples are in mark's
story they are afraid and they see
no way out they feel trapped and
they don't understand why jesus is
letting this happen
so they do what we often do and what
children often do when they feel trapped
they force god's hand
they demand that jesus rescue them
now what we don't know and what even
mark couldn't know
when writing the story is what would
have happened if jesus
stayed asleep and they rode out the
storm
would they have had the capacity within
them as seasoned
veteran fishermen to navigate the storm
would god have rescued them some other
way
and the question no one seemed to think
to ask is
if this jesus who they followed was
indeed the son of god would god
really allow him and them to perish
before his mission was complete
no one was asking this question of
course
none of us think clearly that clearly in
a sudden crisis
i realize i'm asking a lot of the
disciples here
and yet the human instinct remains
when god does not keep difficulty from
coming our way
and when god does not act in the time
frame we think god
should act within we are prone to take
matters into our own hands
and attempt to force god to act on our
behalf
this is true on a personal level as with
me and perhaps with you
when healing doesn't come and it's also
true on a corporate level
when things don't go our way in church
or community
or culture while uh
as don said i our church is is not
southern baptist anymore we left the svc
in
the year 2000 i grew up so in baptist
that's that's
that's where i've come from um i worked
for the denomination for 20 years
along the way in different capacities as
well so i know this
i know this group of people and being
thrust back
to a journalism role now i spent this
past week
a good chunk of this last week listening
to watching and processing what happened
at the southern baptist convention
annual meeting maybe you've read or seen
some of the news out of that it's every
major news outlet in america has covered
it because
it was really significant it's a story
that matters even to those of us who are
not southern baptists
because the sbc is the nation's largest
non-catholic denomination and it's a
bellwether of evangelical thought these
days
what we saw happen in this meeting in
nashville and this really a continuation
of a long-term trend
is multiple attempts to force god's hand
on cultural and social issues that
southern baptists think
aren't getting resolved fast enough
chief among those are abortion and a
fear of losing
white christian privilege the idea seems
to be that by passing
ever stronger resolutions and demanding
more exacting compliance from their own
leaders
southern baptists can force god to reach
down from heaven
and intervene in the issues they believe
culture
is drowning in well the natural outcome
of this way of thinking of course is
turning christian citizens into cultural
warriors
through political action and i don't
have to take time to explain to you
what that looks like because we've been
living through illustrations of this for
some
time now ultimately leading to the
insurrection on our nation's capital
on january 6 that was led by crusading
christians with
a christian flag in their hand really
trying to force god's hand
by taking up arms and storming the seat
of government
what lies at the root of such actions
what causes us
to do things like this it is the fear
that
god is not moving fast enough or clearly
enough
to do the things we believe god ought to
be doing and so we're going to
help god out by taking up the issue
ourselves
and spoiler alert here these things
typically do not work out really well
mark's account of the disciples in the
book jesus
parallels another key bible story that
you may be thinking of
and that's the story of jonah running
away from god's call to preach to the
people of nineveh
now if you remember dig back in your
sunday school days perhaps or your bible
reading hopefully
the way jonah ends up being swallowed by
that giant sea creature
is that he is thrown overboard from a
boat in stormy seas
what's he doing out there he's running
away from the call of god he's trying to
escape
in this jonah attempted to force god's
hand
not by his action but by his stubborn
inaction
which is a reminder that we too can't
attempt to force god's hand
by our resistance to god's plan as well
as by our
unnecessary action on god's behalf it
works both ways
now what about you where do you find
yourself
in this story what is the storm
raging around you that causes you to
think
god is not acting sufficiently to rescue
you or to answer your prayers
what is it that you're resisting doing
for the cause of christ
or what is it you're attempting to force
through with the belief that you're
doing god a big
favor by your action
all of us have blind spots we all have
human agendas
and it's human nature for us to be able
to see these more clearly in other
people than ourselves
right um one of the things i do
along the way is i coach young writers
and i teach writing
and there's a well-worn phrase we use
that's not original with me i think it
actually goes back to the 19th century
uh this advice is a little bit graphic
in its depiction
it's this murder your darlings
murder your darlings and what that means
for writers like me
is to remember that the lines and
phrases that we are most often attached
to
are often the ones that are unnecessary
and need to be cut those little phrases
and things that we're so proud of
that we think are essential to the story
often
they're not they're just our darlings
that we feel good about
those things that we often turn to
and repeat we communicate best when
we're not held captive
to our pet words or phrases that we
alone think
are so beautiful right that's the kind
of insight we need
when we ask how it is that we're
attempting to force god's hand
to we've got to be brutally honest with
ourselves
about why we're doing or not doing
what we are doing it's always easier to
see the faults of others
than to be honest about ourselves
one last word looking at the end of our
story for mark's gospel
after jesus has calmed the storm he
asked the disciples this question
why are you afraid have you still
know faith those are instructive
questions for us today too
we must ask ourselves why we
are afraid and we must ask ourselves
whether we have faith enough to believe
that god is actually at work in the
world
even when we can't see evidence of what
god is doing
why are you afraid
what do you fear that god is not doing
right
for you the answers to these questions
seldom come amid the turbulence of
life's storms
but more often they've been stored up on
the journey leading to the storm
this is how it was with the disciples
who'd been following jesus and learning
from him
and they likely had more faith stored up
than they realized in that moment
that was my experience too what
sustained me through
three years of recovery and adjustment
to my new normal
was not just what i learned in the midst
of the storm
but the ability to draw upon all that i
had stored away
in the years prior we are most prone
to attempt to force god to work on our
behalf
when we have run out of spiritual
resources to draw upon
when the well is dry and we
are in a panic the lesson
is much like the reality of father's day
or mother's day or any of these special
single day holidays we do not honor
fathers today for what they do on this
day
alone instead we honor fathers for what
they have done
and who they have been every day leading
to this day
the disciples they were still learning
this lesson as they journey with jesus
and so are we the more we learn
the more we grow the more we come to
understand
that the words of jesus to the raging
sea
are spoken to us as well peace
be still be
still no
peace amen
would you pray with me lord hear our
prayer as we seek your guidance
to trust you more and to know that you
have our best interest at heart
and that you are working together all
things for our good
even when we cannot see it being done
grant us the faith to trust you more
we pray through jesus christ our lord
amen
thank you mark um we're gonna sing
oceans together
and uh the words of this bridge uh
say spirit lead me where my trust is
without i'm trying to read it all the
way from ryan's
thing over there spirit leave me where
my trust is without borders
and um take me deeper than my feet could
ever wander
and i just as mark was speaking was
thinking of this picture
of sometimes we don't know where god is
calling us
or what he's doing in the midst and we
have those questions and we're much like
the disciples i'm much like a disciple
freaking out and panicking and instead
if i can
do a tran a trust transfer as
i once heard and and apply the trust
that i've built with god through other
seasons into that moment then i'm able
to walk into it with more confidence
knowing that there's something good on
the other side and
um i just want to give you guys a really
quick story i was
talking with a fellow coach the other
day i coached my daughter's
volleyball team and this guy was going
to fill in for me and
we were kind of commiserating sharing
coaching stories and i said
like does it get better when you're
coaching like 10th graders
because my daughter's still a little bit
younger and he was like oh you don't
know half of it
for starters i have three lesbians
on the team and i just stood there kind
of like
oh this conversation is taking a turn
that i didn't realize we were going down
it hit me like i was literally like
silenced you know like where i just
i wish i had words to speak in that
moment but i didn't
and later i was like reflecting and
journaling
because i was carrying some like
frustration shame with myself that i
couldn't have spoken
some truth to that moment um
and i was just writing down like as as
shocked as i was that was the air that i
breathed for the first 25 years of my
life
like that was the culture i was brought
up in that was the belief
system i mean that wouldn't have phased
me you know
10 15 years prior and then it just was
like as i was writing that out
the spirit of god like struck me
and it was like well what is it now
that you think you know that
maybe i want to open you up to something
different like what is it right now that
you're breathing that air and you don't
even realize you know
a different way that i have a different
view that i have from you a different
perspective
um and i just share that with you guys
for one just as kind of my own
confessional to say
you know we don't always have it
together god like i don't have it
together i don't know
all of his ways i'm still learning he's
still transforming me and will be for
the rest of my life
but also just to um kind of invite us
together to take that posture of like
god
open us up to your word for today and
like a new way of seeing the world
and a trust that you're doing something
you're transforming us you're working in
our hearts
to change us in in the ways that we
can't even
see yet you know in the ways that we
don't even realize yet
um so let's just kind of stay in that
posture as we enter into this song
i don't think so
you call me out upon
where feet may fail
and there i find you in the mystery
in oceans deep
my faith will stand
[Music]
and i will call upon your name
and keep my eyes above the waves
when oceans rise my soul will rest in
your embrace
for i am yours
and you are my
[Music]
surrounds me you never
fail and you won't start
[Music]
now
foreign
you are my
[Music]
know
spirit lead me where my trust is without
borders
let me walk upon the waters
wherever you would call me
and take me deeper than my feet could
ever and my
faith will be made stronger
in the presence of my savior
[Music]
and spirit leaves me where my trust is
without borders
let me walk upon the waters
wherever you would call me
and take me deeper than my feet could
ever wander
and my faith will be made stronger
in the presence of my savior
spirit leave me where my trust is
[Music]
take me deeper than my feet
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello
and i will call upon your name
and keep my eyes above the waves
when oceans rise my soul
will rest in your embrace
[Music]
and you are my
let's pray
lord i just pray so much that you just
open up our hearts
our minds to where perhaps we have
forced your hand
perhaps we just haven't had enough where
we just let go trust you
we haven't done a soul searching
i pray you just help us to see those
times in our lives maybe it's this week
maybe it's been today
i pray you give us the wisdom and the
strength just to lean
into you and into your son
in christ and i pray amen
all right so a couple quick little
things so um let's see
if you're a visitor we'd love to hear
from you um we do have some cards
in the back we could just you might just
put your name put some basic information
on the card
um just so we can just have some
information about who your
your visits and everything like that we
appreciate that also
if you resonate with our mission and
vision here at the table
we appreciate you would just show that
appreciation the gift
you can do that by going online you the
website's on the screen
and you can also drop i think there's a
box in the back
yes awesome where you can be able to do
that as well and then there's another
way to give by texting as well
and to lead us i'm just going to do a
quick
uh just kind of send off um i love this
i keep coming back to this because it's
simple it's a simple
but it hits kind of home at the same
time every single time i read it
um this is from number six
may the lord bless and keep you may the
lord's face
shine upon you and be gracious to you
and may the lord turn his face towards
you
and give you peace thank you have a good
rest of your evening
[Music]
you